nehmen jetzt einfach the last raus so
meinst du das einfach nur so
das richtige tut
herzlich willkommen zur deutsche team
heute endlich ein teil der essen testen
reihe kommt der unbedingt kommen musste
und zwar testen wie heute essen dass
meine mutter immer gast hat meine mutter
ist heute mit dabei und wird uns ihre
meinung zu den ausgewählten
lebensmitteln kundtun maxi sind der
kamera wird gleich auch testen was ich
auch meiner mutter übrigens oder das
nach gerade mit dem test leute
aufgefallen wären video zwar halten das
hier
ich habe an der backe so eine beule wie
siehst du das hier sieht so aus aber das
hat nichts mit weißer zehnten mal das
ist schon lange raus und danach ist hier
einfach so eine schwellung und beim
zahlen falsch aufgetreten ist
vorneweg sogar sagen damit den schreibt
der backe luft leute ich habe schon mal
die ganze sache auch ein tablett das ist
das ist eine kombination nicht was diese
lebensmittel sich jemals in der form
zusammen gesehen haben auch am tablett
geschweige in einem einkaufswagen aber
jetzt hier angefangen ich sitz hier um
so viele leute drüben jetzt meine kalten
sitzt meine mutter außerhalb von der
kamera ihr müsst ihr euch das macht mich
zeigt die eigentlich nicht weil keine
negative aufmerksamkeit auf die ziehen
naja wir froh wenn ich meine fahrzeuge
ihr wisst was ich meine leute also
einfach nicht mehr meine familie besten
schützen und nicht so in die
öffentlichkeit einfach zeichen
reinziehen
fangen wir aber der ersten sache die ich
auf diesem wunderschönen tablett vor
meinem antlitz erblicke und zwar aber
ich bin zu halten wir probieren jetzt
mal grüne paprika
sag mal ganz kurz was ist so die sache
die ich ein grüner paprika stört also
grüne paprika kann man eigentlich
überhaupt nicht beißen und wenn man sie
dann doch kaum muss das musik
runtergeschluckt und wenn das man so
noch geht dann kann man sie auf jeden
fall nicht verdauen
das ist sowas ekelhaftes also grüne
paprika ist quasi so einen lebensmittel
ein gemüse was einfach nicht
funktioniert auch nicht im gekochten
zustand da geht gar nicht das hab ich
auch noch nie gesehen ist vollmer grüne
gekochte paprika gesehen weil es
überhaupt in dem sinne stürzt sich wenn
wir beide von der pieke abweisen also
zuversichtlich es gibt die zu schneiden
ich weiß nicht ob wir dann noch meine
seite wirst du bist meine mutter ist
eine sehr gute köchin und die ist sehr
alt noch sehr sehr fein glauben was die
sache angeht und einfach sowas
reinweißen gibt eigentlich gar nicht
aber finde ich aber auch nicht gut
irgendwie schmeckt selbst würde daran
gerochen und geschmeckt
da will ich einfach nach wiese aber
jetzt mal probiert hat das wir sind das
video ist das ausprobieren
ich hatte auch paprika der höhe also
allgemein der wende hatte gab es nur mit
grün hat sich ja nicht raus sagen ich
hab's gemacht und das schmeckt also wie
wiesen also wenn man so grabka und oder
schmeckt mich so als als west zum essen
geraten
ok ich probiere auch okay nächste sache
das ist echt cool wird die ganze hand
nehme ich habe mir selbst eine wurde die
sich unterdurchschnittlich sind die
zuschauer sind jetzt aber gar nicht hat
er wirklich hunger gehabt
das kasperle theater machen hatte echte
paprika
ferner sollte was ist grüne paprika für
einen fall damit alter so schmeckt
einfach nicht das egal
so schmeckt mir einfach weh diese aber
die farbe grün macht müsste so
unterschiedlich ja also rote paprika iwf
gelbe paprika bisschen süße oder doch
vielleicht ist ja die die grüne paprika
einfach eine unreife paprika also um die
verkaufen die unreifen informiert weil
ich habe erst eineinhalb und rot in
einer packung kauft ja leute ich sehe
jetzt noch drei weitere dinge hier vor
mir eine sache ist komisch habe ich noch
nie gegessen eine andere ist lecker als
dessert und die dritte ich habe wirklich
bock da einzuweisen ich meine dass wir
eine dose cola dose gesagt ich will
nicht zu sehr ist die zweite sache die
meine mutter stimmer gast hier jetzt
testen werden max vielleicht auch mal
über das auch mitmachen sind dosen
ravioli manchmal ganz kurz zu dir waren
sehr zweifelhaften ihr müsst ihr
gesichtsausdruck sehen ist es doch mal
meine söhne mit youtube angefragt warum
muss ich jetzt machen das ganze zeug
produkte das ist einfach toll ich das
stinkt das schlägt nach gar nichts und
es hat null nährwerte ist es einfach zum
kotzen wenn er dich fertig ist bitte
schön geil geil geil
das ist nicht länger antun
wenn ich wenn ich hunger hätte und der
ganz die ganze küche wäre leere dose von
dem zeug stünde da ich würde somit drei
gläser wasser trinken
das ist so ich finde es gibt klar das
ist kein riesiger hoch gewusst aber ist
das lecker ich habe ja eine extra mache
ich nicht mit bestehenden anders nicht
ein bisschen druck da muss man probieren
max gehört
okay was machst du hier das hat sich
nicht auf sofas tja also lecker ist
jetzt wahrscheinlich anders
so wird's gemacht entweder den topf in
eine mikrowelle oder aber die sind ja
schon vorgekommen
ja also sonst sterben wir halt anfangen
sich wirklich wie seine kinder passt die
man als kind in einem restaurant
bekommen
das einfach so naja so nichts sagen ist
das ist kein skandal es keinen vertrag
nicht so weil es eine für kinder ist
aber ist halt wirklich so nichts aber
das ist nicht schlimm aber die
konsistenz die sind wie ein bisschen
besorgniserregend wenn ich aber ich
finde ich finde es auch nicht so schlimm
dass ich sagen würde wenn ich keinen
hunger wenn ich hunger
ich finde es jetzt auch nicht so schlimm
dass ich nicht essen würde wenn ich
hunger hätte aber ich will es mir
niemals kaufen also wirklich nicht aber
es gibt also man kann zu essen kann man
schon da verstehst du dass meine mutter
dadurch nicht weil die eigenen wünsche
ist dass meine mutter das nicht ist ja
verstehe ich meine mutter ist
tatsächlich auch nicht zu kurz kommen
wir zur nächsten sache meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren an diesem
wunderbaren abend wir uns kurz was die
zuschauer sollten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das kind habe mir das wirklich wirklich
wenn meine zuschauer aber auch mal
leihweise in einem video einfach nicht
nur wie youtube sondern erst mal live
dabei deutlich ab
ich schaue mich ja nicht an ich hab mich
anleger die wollen irgendwie dass
irgendwas zu essen geben oder sowas
[Gelächter]
kommt zur nächsten sache wollte ich
gerade eben sagen und zwar ist es wieder
eine sache aus dem bereich grünzeug das
ist die sache die ich in der form wie
ich jetzt erst wer dann noch nie
gegessen habe never durch aber zeigen ja
und zwar noch mehr gratis werden einmal
gras und paprika vorm rathaus
[Musik]
das muss aber dass das ist ja super mit
totem fisch kombinieren zum beispiel
lachs das wird erst jetzt weil aber
jeder sondern hast du geboren bist du
dich da ist ein bisschen wasser in denen
ich habe mit gewohnt macht nicht so der
papst
manchmal geht er nicht so so die welt so
der papst
warum ist dein kind und [ __ ] und ja
natürlich weiß 3000 menschen
tipp jetzt kommentare herz unserer
mutter ruhe so gesagt ist nicht so bei
uns ist es so dass sowie domino sowie
halo okay sagte lammert
ich nehme jetzt aber so ist raus so
meinst du das einfach noch so zufall ab
und legt dann muss man so zerreiben geil
ist geil ist nicht mal den max gibt es
mir super das ist als ob das nicht geil
ich das richtig weh so beleidigt ich
will einfach so eine salat zusagen
machen jetzt bitte bitte bitte so kefer
musik nein das ist wirklich lecker
lecker oder ist ein bisschen dass man
das muss ich weiß nicht
kommen wir zur hütte also sehr haben wir
einmal bisher es ist wirklich ein fan
des handys her
nennen wir es schokoprodukte macht kein
geld mehr als kapital dem himmels willen
die wir ja erst jetzt der polizei lässt
jetzt gemessen die die wahlscheine den
ersten lacher ich muss dazu sagen ich
bin normalerweise auch kein mensch der
schokopudding mag aber ich glaube das
könnte ich jetzt kicken weil das habe
ich schon ein bisschen angedacht daher
war gefühlt nur sarah greif weil das ist
aus unserer perspektive unserer bin ich
gesagt unsere da man mich und zuschauer
was ich mir die liebe zuschauer haben
wir das gelassen
stimmt ja aber die hier licon
kommentiert ihr mehrere kitty zumal
dieses video lassen kommentare ob ihr
die bessere zuschauer seit überhaupt die
auf dem tisch die wir so zu sprechen und
schmeckt lecker was gerade nicht würde
ich auch laufen aber noch bitte einmal
diesen wunderbaren das waren die viele
lebensmittel meine mutter immer gas
heute an der stelle müssen wir bitte
eine runde applaus gibt für meine mutter
können die zuschauer bitte auch christa
chen ohne abend wie immer das schreiben
heute gezeigt und lebensmitteln gerne in
die kommentare können darüber
diskutieren was jetzt wirklich eklig ist
und was nicht check hier ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video ab max
abschreibung von lenks meine mutter
nicht weil jetzt kein youtube facebook
pages